yes today I am so excited because
activation has once again reached out to
me to test out their latest games I
think they did this by mistake I think
they sent it too early because I have
the new Call of Duty World War 2 I was
just checking my email randomly and
there it was Erick Richburg
yo dawg love your weeds it's a copy of
the game Eric thank you so much I really
appreciate that you let me be the first
exclusive and that you didn't give it to
these other peasant youtubers like a
nadeshot or [ __ ] because Eric knows I
am the biggest Call of Duty fan ever
like I I love Call of Duty ever since I
was born they haven't really showed much
footage of the game they just showed a
trailer amazing it they really showed
the innovation here of World War two you
know I'm sure he wasn't at all like EA
made battlefield where world wanted
they're like well respected
it's like they did the [ __ ] title
pattern full game or whatever
I got popular and it finally looked like
a decent contender to cook - call of
duty
and Call of Duty was like yeah little
back let's do that boo boo beta cubed a
should be done at this point I am pretty
sure that EA and Activision they're just
on the front of their seat being like
come on come on World War three
we need more footage we need more
content to make games out of we clearly
run out of all options it's like the
thing since they've done it all
it's like Beta Pi they're random person
like this I mean what could they
possibly do that hasn't been done before
they they cycle
I guess they restart now you know we
went through the space let's go back to
World War one literally we've just seen
the trailer of the game and of course
polygon is all about all of that [ __ ]
Call of Duty World War two checks all
the diversity boxes but it's still the
story of a white man small you wanted to
change what happened or am I missing but
you're not educated there was minorities
there was yes maybe but they didn't all
fight together
okay females and males did not fight
together as far as I know listen I'm not
a Nestorian and also who gives a [ __ ]
Call of Duty's world where choose
diversity is nothing more than marketing
how dare they what was the [ __ ] Pepsi
commercial leg like what is all
companies trying to do with diversity
literally Hollywood in general they're
all just trying to get diversity and so
people will stop complaining sorry
that's another video like they don't
give a [ __ ] companies don't give a [ __ ]
companies are evil have we forgotten
about this of course or whatever
diversity they put in a [ __ ] a
[ __ ] dumbasses Jesus Christ you know
I love Cod for and I love cod v but
somewhere along the line they just
decided to stop making games and as just
start making ape [ __ ] [ __ ] crazy
crazy [ __ ] but I guess you can only put
that so far so now Call of Duty
medieval addiction Stone Age edition
where's as far back as you can
like what was the first war that had gun
you know I actually that might be a cool
Call of Duty wouldn't it yeah I take it
back I would play that [ __ ] look at that
guy he's having fun all right but enough
rants but enough tantrum let's just play
the game I'm so excited to finally be
playing it also I have I have another
copy of the game they said I could do a
giveaway so be sure to smash that like
button and share it everywhere so people
know the real Call of Duty and there's a
lot of fake fake ones out there so
really be sure you share and like so
that people will find the real one which
is this one okay none of that on a fake
once here we go let's play I'm excited
Oh deines wow they really took a bold
bold determined or bold step with this
one so we play in Berlin 1942 it sort of
looks like the half-life engine but I'm
pretty sure they really did a great job
oh here we go should I be on the Allies
or the Nazis I obviously I'm not gonna
be some [ __ ] now
[Applause]
all right here we go I'm really glad
they stay true to what the real story
behind in World War two was [ __ ]
dinosaurs
okay everyone knows there was [ __ ]
dinosaurs and if you don't know then
open your eyes people all right let's
think we could get at some quickscope on
this [ __ ] go nailed it
[ __ ] [ __ ] Oh Jimmy I'm sorry I'm sorry
Adam Adam Adam [ __ ] I was so close
I'll get him next time as they go right
there
target neutralized Oh No
oh they got I got our leader o sons of
[ __ ]
[ __ ] Nazi scum all right I think I
see my problem here I'm playing at the
wrong dinosaur I needed this as the one
in two classes
[Music]
come on Dinah run
you got a flag Danny Boy [ __ ] they're
bombing us ah son of a Dino
yeah ah nah I hate me alive
[ __ ] benefit war war is where is the
bad thing in this game really displaced
that excellent ah help me you ask the
worst game
[Music]
Gautam Gautam that's right see if it I
mean out here hunting Gannicus for year
Oh Dana ah quick [ __ ] welcome down worry
written the graphics in the chick
honestly this might be the best Call of
Duty game I have ever possibly die you
die notes comeback
[ __ ] stop jumpin you ass
oh stop leave me uh maybe the [ __ ] ha
[ __ ] cover me cover me get up
God died full of duty or war never
changes I can't believe this is when my
granddad went through just kidding he
was in Swedish Oh God not again
I saved your life States oh my god
get up get up [ __ ] I'm out I'm out I'm
[ __ ] out I'm done I'm so [ __ ] done
war never changes not sex full never
changes not you [ __ ] stop stop moved
up [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ]
die die you dinosaur Scout bags
where'd he go where'd he go
[ __ ] you get up get up so Steve where's
Steven you [ __ ] need it I hear you
you naughty peevish dick that's [ __ ]
right dinosaurs will conquer are you
southern [ __ ]
Oh son of a [ __ ] no no god damn all
right that's all that's all I'm allowed
to show right now I don't want to I
don't want to upset anyone at Activision
yeah it's really interesting to see
where they're going with this one a lot
of surprises that didn't initially show
in the trailer if you think this wasn't
real okay because I know a lot of haters
a lot of haters are not going to think
aw you're just playing another game
Felix well first of all look at all the
likes and shut the [ __ ] up second of all
I'm going to do a giveaway here because
they also sent me in this box they sent
me the first-ever version of this game
and I thought okay wouldn't it be nice
wouldn't it be nice of me to give it to
one of you guys so I might if you want
to win oh my god the cover looks so good
if you want to win this be sure to smash
that like apply for an Amazon $100 gift
and you could you could win this this
this copy of this game you could be
owning a piece of history also I want to
thank everyone exhibition for all your
love and support I love you guys and
thank you guys my fans my bros you guys
are the best
love you guys thank you and let's always
which one is he gonna do which is both
of them
you